bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux alors je sais que ça peut faire
drôle de voir les paléo news revenir
après deux ans et demi d'absence
mais j'ai décidé de ressusciter un peu
ce format pour pouvoir vous parler de
l'actualité scientifique mais cette fois
un peu plus d'un point de vue critique
donc ça va être des paléo news non
scriptée contrairement à avant et ça va
surtout être l'occasion de comparer bien
ce que dit la presse comparé à ce que
disent les articles scientifiques donc
pour vous très chers auditeurs ça va
être l'occasion de découvrir le
véritable contenu des articles
scientifiques
alors on commence tout de suite parce
qu'on a du pain sur la planche avec
cette image
cette image que vous avez certainement
vu passer donc dans la presse qui est
très jolie une vue alors c'est pas une
vue thermique d'un dinosaure et de
crocodile alors ils disent que c'est ce
sont d'un das plateau aux russes et des
des innocents cus donc évidemment que
c'est pas une véritable vue en caméra
thermique
c'est une reconstruction d'une caméra
thermique donc niveau artistique
il ya de la prouesse technique 1 quand
même de ce point de vue là et donc ça ça
ça a pu vous faire penser quand vous
l'avez vu passer dans vos fils
d'actualité ça a pu vous faire penser à
un article qui parlerait d'en doter
remis en fait de dévolution de
métabolisme à sang chaud chez les
dinosaures
et bien il n'en est rien voilà voilà
deux ans on commence un il n'en est rien
donc voici le titre de l'article de la
fosse frontaux pariétal de la fenêtre
dorsaux temporal des archosaures et sa
signification pour l'interprétation des
structures vasculaires de l'anatomie des
dinosaures grosso modo traduit un donc
qu'est ce à dire que ceux ci qu'est ce
que ça veut dire que tout ça bon alors
déjà première première chose qu'il faut
analyser quand on lit un article c'est
les auteurs donc qui sont ses jambes
je ne sais pas qui sont ces gens en
réalité à part laurence wittner qui est
le dernier auteur et la position de
dernier auteur veut dire que c'était lui
en gros le chef de l'équipe et laurence
wittner lui il est très connu parce que
tous quasiment tout ce que vous avez pu
voir passer en matière de dinosaures qui
où il ya des reconstructions en fait du
cerveau alors toutes ces images vous
voyez le cerveau enfin audi pas cerveau
normalement on dit en doc ramener enfin
on va appeler ça un cerveau sera plus
simple donc toutes les reconstructions
de cerveaux que vous avez pu voir passer
sur internet où le cerveau et bleu voilà
donc les reconstructions de cerveau
dinosaures ou le cerveau et bleu et le
crâne et en transparent
c'est laurence wittner voilà ou alors ça
a été très fortement influencé par
laurence wittner mais sait il s'est
vraiment imposé comme le leader en
matière d'étude des structures
neurologique chez les espèces éteintes
en particulier chez les dinosaures et du
coup c'est lui le leader de cette équipe
d'illustrés inconnus en tout cas pour
moi je sais que casey holliday y est
assez connue parce que cette personne a
publié bien d'autres articles dans la
même veine mais je les ai pas lues moi
même donc voilà donc déjà les auteurs
c'est plutôt du sérieux à laurence
wittner c'est quand même c'est quand
même quelque chose d'assez sérieux et
alors cet article est bien ce qu il nous
décrit c'est une structure qui est très
connu chez les chez les dinosaures qui
s'appelle la fosse lasky qui est une
fausse en fait qui se trouve dans la
fosse temporal supérieur
alors si je peux vous montrer une jolie
image parce que les jolies images autant
l'article est très bien illustré autant
pour les non spécialistes c'est
extrêmement obscur de comprendre ce qui
se passe donc une image qui illustrerait
bien le concept
laissez-moi trouvé ça ohlala
il est vraiment très difficile à
comprendre cet article voilà donc quand
vous regardez au sommet d'un crâne il me
semble que là on doit quand même
relativement comprendre ce qui se passe
mais quand vous regardez le sommet d'un
crâne de dinosaures en fait vous avez
les fausses temporal donc vous avez les
deux fosses temporal typique du crâne
d'un dinosaure les deux fosses dit
apside est en fait à l'avant de la fosse
temporal du dessus il y à une fausse une
fosse à l'intérieur de la fosse voilà
donc c'est une double fausse c'est une
acception de fausses si vous préférez
donc là vous avez le dessin là on a une
vue qui est semi latéral quoi presque vu
de côté un peu vu de côté un peu vu du
dessus et donc ce que vous voyez en fait
c'est la fausse temporal avec la leur
bord de la fosse temporal qui forment
une autre dépression à l'intérieur de la
fosse temporal et à l'intérieur de cette
fausse et bien on savait pas ce qui s'y
passait donc donc ils sont allés
disséquer des crocodiles donc ça c'est
une des images qu'on a vu avant voilà
donc ils sont allés disséquer des
crocodiles donc là vous avez un crâne de
crocodile vue du dessus
les crocodiles ont cette fausse temporal
et à la vente cette fausse temporal eh
bien ils ont découvert qu'ils avaient
des organes déjà c'est intéressant de
savoir qu'on découvre encore des organes
chez les crocodiles 1 alors que c'est
des espèces modernes et c'est
intéressant aussi de savoir que c'est
des paléontologues qui doivent aller
disséquer les crocodiles moderne pour
pour comprendre ce qui se passe chez les
animaux moderne donc ça c'est déjà déjà
ça vous montre une des facettes qu'on
montre pas beaucoup de la paléontologie
qui est que la paléontologie est
extrêmement dépendante des coûts de ce
qu'on sait des animaux moderne puisque
c'est notre seul point de repère et que
de temps en temps le paléontologue est
obligé de faire du travail de néons aux
logs
deux biologistes quoi pour arriver à
comprendre ces fossiles donc là c'est un
très très bon exemple de ça donc ils ont
disséqué des crocodiles ils les ont
scanné aussi on voit qu'il ya des images
de scan ici et ils ont reconstruit ce
qui se passait dans cette petite fosse
est en fait ils ont découvert tout un
système vasculaire à l'intérieur de ces
petites fosses et ce système vasculaire
en fait ils en ont ils ont fait des
images thermiques de crocodile donc je
crois qu'on voit ça un peu plus loin
dans l'article si on descend voilà donc
ils ont fait des images thermiques de
crocodile pour se rendre compte qu'en
fait ce système vasculaire
il servait à l'animal à refroidir en
fait son cerveau donc ça c'est ce que
vous voyez ici vous voyez le sommet du
crâne du crocodile on voit ces yeux-là
est en fait vous voyez que la même les
fausses
or les fausses temporal sont bien plus
chaude que les yeux eux mêmes
pardon est-ce que c'est plus chaud plus
froid oui regardez les celle là c'est
plus chaud donc elles sont bien plus
chaude que les que les ul eux-mêmes et
donc c'est par là en fait que le
crocodile relâche de la chaleur et du
coup ils en ont déduit et bien que les
dinosaures faisait de même avec leurs
propres fausse temporal donc là vous
voyez on a quand même c'est toujours
un site d'attachement musculaire mais
maintenant on a une nouvelle
interprétation qui est qu'en fait on est
passé d'une vieille interprétation ici
en haut où toute la fosse temporal
servait d'insertion musculaire y compris
cette fausse à l'avant de la fosse
temporal et en fait non la fosse à
l'avant de la fosse temporal elle
n'était pas pour des insertions
musculaire selon eux elle serait plutôt
pour ses tissus vasculaires
avec un peu de tissu adipeux c'est ce
qui représente en jaune là donc si on
fait un zoom voilà on voit le ce tissus
vasculaires donc tous ses vaisseaux qui
viennent directement du cerveau ou des
structures environnantes et qui viennent
relâcher leur chaleur en fait et vous
voyez même qu'ils ont un système de à
contre-courant qui permet aussi si si
besoin est en fait d'empêcher la chaleur
de partir puisque le sens arrive dans
les artères ici en rouge
et si jamais ils veulent animal a besoin
de conserver sa chaleur haut lieu de
l'art largué en fait vous voyez qu'il ya
la veine à côté qui suit en bleu et
cette veine en fait il suffit qu'elle se
gonfle pour former un système de
refroidissement à contre-courant en fait
où la veine qui est plein de sang froid
va récupérer la chaleur de l'artère qui
elle a du sang chaud donc c'est un
système c'est un système qui est connu
chez d'autres animaux mais c'est la
première fois qu'on le met finalement en
évidence chez les archosaures et du coup
vu que la plupart des dinosaures ont une
fausse comme ça et ça il me semble que
c'est même un t-rex elle est très très
grosse chez les t-rex
oui c'est ça en plus tyrannosaurus donc
chez les t-rex il ya une très très
grosse fausse et ben c'est la première
fois aussi qu'on met en évidence ce
système de refroidissement
et ça ça a d'énormes implications mais
pas forcément pour landau thermie parce
qu'en fait les oiseaux aussi on ce
système là donc vous avez les crocodiles
à sang froid qui ont un système de à
contre-courant et de refroidissement
mais vous avez aussi les animaux à sang
chaud que sont les oiseaux qui ont ce
système donc ça nous permet pas vraiment
de savoir si les dinosaures étaient oui
ou non à son show par contre ce qui est
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est que les
c'est que les ceyrat obtient en fait ils
ont des fausses
très grande donc si vous regardez le
crâne de j'essaie de trouver un cerrato
psia mais je crois qu'ils en ont pas
beaucoup dans cet article les cerrato
pfizer de très grandes fosses temporal
vous prenez par exemple la torosaurus le
très controversé torosaurus il
ad'énormes fenêtre danser il ad'énormes
fenêtre dans sa collerette et en fait
ces fenêtres ce sont les équivalents de
défausse temporal supérieur et donc
pareil si vous suit si vous regardez des
photos sur internet de torosaurus ou de
n'importe quel ceyrat obtient vous
verrez qu en fait à l'intérieur de ses
fenêtres il y a des petites dépressions
c'est particulièrement visible sur proto
ceratops d'ailleurs proto ceratops à
d'être des fausses très profonde
j'essaie de retrouver en même temps où
se trouve proto ceratops c'est le d donc
voilà ça c'est proto ceratops vue du
dessus
vous voyez les fausses temporal et vous
voyez qu'à l'avant et autour des fausses
temporal il y a encore des dépressions
en fait donc c'est la leçon très
évidente chez proto ceratops et en fait
ça ça devait contenir ce fameux système
à contre-courant ce fameux système
d'artères de vaines et tissus adipeux
qui servent à se réchauffer quand il
fait trop froid ou à se refroidir quand
il fait trop chaud donc donc ça cesse et
si il y avait de la vascularisation de
là dedans et basse ça peut avoir aidé
aussi les ceratops ya à voir coloré leur
collerette puisque vous savez que ça
c'est une des très grosses d'hypothèses
qui traîne en ce moment c est ce que est
ce que ces trous là dans les collerettes
ils n'étaient pas remplies avec du tissu
qui était capable de changer de couleur
en fonction de la dilatation des
vaisseaux et bien il se trouve que cet
article tend à le confirmer en fait
bon encore une fois on n'a pas de
préservation de tissus mous donc donc ça
reste de l' hypothèse mais l'hypothèse
s'étoffe avec cet article donc système
de refroidissement ou de réchauffement
et possiblement du coup l utilisation de
ces deux cévennes pour pouvoirs colorés
les collerettes chez les ceyrat obtient
donc on attend avec impatience la suite
de cette étude qui parce que parce
qu'ils annoncent qu'il va y avoir une
suite
dans cet article et on est impatient de
savoir quelles vont-être toutes les
extensions qui vont pouvoir trouver à
cette découverte
on continue avec
les dc nos dons alors les dix innovantes
qui sont les terras psid l'airé qui sont
des terres à petit ces reptiles maliens
qui avaient un bec qui était de
généralement de taille moyenne mais on
en a découvert de très très gros vous
avez peut-être entendu parler de l'iso
vie chiaki qui a été découvert en
pologne et qui devait alors les
estimations 19 tonnes mais elles ont été
revues à la baisse récemment on
parlerait plus de 5 à 7 tonnes ce qui
paraît logique parce que l'animal au
final est de la taille d'un il est de la
taille d'un rhinocéros alors je vois pas
pourquoi ils feraient le poids d'un
éléphant avec avec la taille d'un
rhinocéros mais bref je m'égare donc
lady synodaux dont on pense et bien
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont survécu jusqu'au
crétacé à cause d'un seul fossiles que
je cherche sur cet article et le voici
le fameux fossiles voilà ce fossile
croyez le ou non mais il s'agirait en
gros d'une d'un morceau de près
maxillaire de dissin aux dons avec une
défense tourner vers le bas qui serait
donc caractéristiques d'un dc 90
et ça ça a fait couler encore une fois
beaucoup d'encre parce que si jamais ce
truc là c'est un morceau de dissin aux
dons dans le crétacé ça veut dire que
lesdits synodaux ont survécu bien plus
longtemps qu'on ne l'imaginait puisque
normalement les dinosaures se sont
éteints au trias et non pas au crétacé
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe késako
l'hypothèse qui flottait en gros avant
la publication de cet article est bien
c'est que c'était un se dessine au dos
ayant été retrouvées en australie et
bien il s'agissait d'un survivant de la
même manière que les marsupiaux et les
mots notres m sont des survivants en
australie de la même manière que les
amphibiens temenos pondent ils ont
survécu jusqu'au crétacé en australie
alors qu'ils se sont éteints partout
ailleurs bien avant ça donc
donc voilà l'hypothèse qu'il hypothèse
qui était plutôt séduisante au final le
bien c'était que les dc nos dons avaient
survécu très très longtemps isolé en
australie et en fait cet article eh bien
il démolit complètement cette cette
possibilité donc je vous montre le titre
de l'article comme ça vous pourrez aller
le chercher
vous même si ça vous intéresse alors
pour l'instant il est encore à l'état de
manuscrits parce que c'est une
c'est une prépublication mais bon il est
il est accessible publiquement donc
c'est pas un problème
alors voilà s'agit-il du dernier
si nos donc une réévaluation en fait de
la taxonomie est dû et du temporel
relation chip alors ce serait là la
disposition dans le temps d'un fossile
australien conflictuelle contentieux
conflictuelle voilà et donc ce qu'ils
ont découvert en fait c'est bah c'est
qu'en regardant dans les collections il
souhaite ce petit bout là de que je vous
montre de défense avec dupré maxillaires
en fait et ben il n'était pas tout seul
il n'était pas tout seul dans les
collections où il a été retrouvé
parce que ah oui il faut évidemment il
faut refaire tout l'historique de ce
petit morceau d'os avant ça donc en fait
ce morceau d'os il n'a pas été découvert
par les scientifiques directement sur le
terrain il a été découvert par un
fermier donc sur le terrain de sa ferme
au début du 19e au début du 20e siècle
il a été ramené au musée et il a été
oublié là en gros et c'est seulement en
2013 que quelqu'un s'est dit vote
je vais l'étudier à la dent je regarde
si c'est bien en 2013
est ce que c'est en 2013 ou est-ce que
c'était en 2003 ce qu'ils en parlent
est-ce que vous en parlez quelque part
oui en 2003 voilà tu le borgne et turner
qui on proposait donc qu'il s'agissait
d'un dc 90 survivants
voilà donc en 2003 il ya quelqu'un qui
le retrouve dans les collections sur le
tube born et turner le retrouve dans les
collections et le publie en dix ans les
10 synodaux ont survécu jusqu'au crétacé
c'est la seule explication possible est
en fait ce qu'on fait les auteurs de cet
article de ce nouvel article qui ne sont
pas de turner et tu le borgne mais qui
sont que nielsen et ourle pour le mann's
oui bah parce que c'est un fossile
c'est un fossile qui je crois a se
trouve dans les collections de tübingen
alors c'est en allemagne du coup c'est
des allemands qui étudie et bien en fait
ils se sont rendus compte que ce fossile
il promenait pas tout seul et il se
promener avec d'autres petits fragments
osseux et notamment un notamment un que
je vais vous montrer qui a des dents et
alors là ça c'est des danses et des
dents quadrangulaire donc en forme de
rectangle et below faut donc c'est à
dire qu'ils ont de l'ofs
chacune est alors quand on trouve des
grosses dents quadrangulaire et below
faut donc en australie la première chose
à laquelle on pense c'est certainement
pas un dissidente puisque lesdits sinon
donc n'avait pas dedans en tout cas pas
de poste canine
il avait une grosse canine et c'est tout
pour la plupart non la première chose à
laquelle on pense et bien c'est un 10
proto d'hondt c'est à dire un monde bat
un bon bah de géant et
et donc le bal à sa caste ou quoi ça
vous détruit tout le mythe non c'était
pas un dc 90 en fait ça appartenait à
mon badge et ans alors c'est la seule en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'ils
étaient juste pas stockés dans la même
boîte quoi c'est tout ce morceau avec
des dents et le morceau avec la canine
mais enfin avec la la défense devrais-je
dire parce que c'est pas vraiment une
canine eux il leur est interprète comme
une incisive du coup donc ce morceau
avec les dents avec les molaires et le
morceau avec la défense il était juste
pas dans la même boîte et même de toute
façon en réexaminant la défense et en
s'imaginant que il n'était pas dans la
même boîte parce qu'ils viennent pas du
même endroit
ben ça marche pas non plus parce que ils
ont city scanner donc ils ont ils ont
analysé par rayons x
voilà ils ont fait des radiographies de
cette dent est en fait ils se sont
rendus compte aussi que la dent n'avait
de l'émail que une très fine couche
d'émail que sur la face avant est pas
sur la face arrière donc c'est ce que
vous voyez en rouge là et ça c'est ça
c'est important parce que lesdits
synodaux eux ils avaient ils avaient de
l'émail tout autour de la dent pas
seulement sur la face avant et ça par
contre ça colle très bien avec encore
une fois une identification à 1,10 proto
dont tu donc ben et ben tout s'effondre
quoi alors qu'est ce qui avait conduit
finalement les premiers auteurs à penser
que qu'il s'agissait d'un dc nos
d'autres survivants du crétacé bonne
question
l'espoir certainement l'espoir d'avoir
trouvé quelque chose de très intéressant
mais non en fait ce petit bout de ce
petit bout qu'ils ont trouvé finalement
c'était juste une des incisives en fait
dudit proto dompter voilà le bout de
maxillaire avec les grosses molaires tel
qu'il devait s'attacher au crâne
original et la raison et là ils ont même
refait des datations pour dire si oui ou
non ça venait du crétacé en fait ça non
ça vient pas non plus du crétacé donc
parce qu'à la limite 1 10 proto nom du
crétacé ça aurait été vachement
intéressant mais même là non en fait ça
vient pas ça semble pas venir du crétacé
ils ont fait des analyses des enfin ils
ont fait des datations avec des isotopes
radioactifs est en fait c'est datation
montre que ça vient du alors ça ça
montre que ça vient pas du crétacé le
signal est pas très propre on va dire
c'est à dire que les différents os donne
pas les mêmes dates
donc il ya probablement un truc qui
s'est produit il ya eu trop de
manipulations peut-être ou ou peut-être
et alors peut-être et c'est la dernière
hypothèse c'est qu'en fait les rapports
qui date du début du xxème siècle donc
faut quand même mettre des grosses
guillemets dessus indique que le fossile
a été trouvé dans une dans une région en
fête où il ya du crétacé il ya des
sédiments crétacé et au dessus des
sédiments du crétacé il ya d une couche
volcaniques qui date de la fin du
cénozoïque donc peut-être quaternaire
peut être plié au pléistocène on sait
pas exactement est en fait le dit proto
dont enfin les fossiles dont il s'agit
aurait été trouvé au dessus d'eux ils
ont été trouvés dans dans une petite
vallée d'érosion qui était au dessus du
crétacé donc ils l'on trouvait en fait
dans le
donc c'est facile il aurait été trouvé
dans une ravine une petite ravine mais
qui est donc il était décrocher
complètement il était plus en contexte
sédimentaires mais il était au dessus
au fait en fait du crétacé donc il était
dans la partie dans la partie volcanique
et du cou enfin ils ont attribué par
défaut ces fossiles à la couche
sédimentaire la plus proche qui est le
crétacé
mais pour se retrouver là il y aurait
quand même fallu qu'ils défient les lois
de la gravité quoi ces fossiles de 10
proto dons ou de dissin aux dons
supposés donc donc on était un peu
coincé et alors bon maintenant on sait
quand même que il est possible de
retrouver des fossiles dans des dans des
couches volcaniques un les les
empreintes de pas de là et au lit par
exemple ils ont été faits dans de la
cendre volcanique et on a même découvert
un crâne de rhinocéros dans une couche
de l'avs
un crâne de rhinocéros du mio scène dans
une couche de l'avs donc des fois ça
arrive quand même que les fossiles soit
préservée soit préservée dans des roches
volcaniques s'est pas complètement
impossible si vous êtes intéressé par le
rhinocéros dans les couches de l'avs
il a été découvert en turquie et c'est
un paléontologue français pierre olivier
antoine qu'il l'a décrit l'article
s'intitule cooked tout df donc cuisiner
à mort dont vous le trouverez assez
facilement il me semble qu'il est open
access donc bref là où je voulais en
venir c'est qu'en gros il ya encore un
truc qui va pas avec ceux avec la
provenance du crétacé de cette chose
c'est qu'il a été découvert au dessus du
crétacé au final donc il a été attribué
au crétacé par défaut parce que c'était
la couche sédimentaire d'à côté quoi
mais il ya peu de chances qu'ils
proviennent du crétacé et donc le
problème c'était les datations voilà les
datations en fait elles ont pu être
perturbés par le fait que si le si les
fossiles proviennent de la couche
volcanique il est possible que la chimie
donc qui est la base finalement de des
datations ait été perturbé par le fait
qu'il se soit que le fossile se soit
formée en condition dans des roches
volcaniques quoi donc bon les datations
marche pas vraiment et elle donne des
âges très différent elle donne même il
ya même un des âges qui est permien ou
dévonien quoi donc c'est vraiment des
datations qui valent pas grand chose
je veux dire 10 proto dont on est à peu
près sûr que ça vient pas du dévonien
sans trop se tromper
donc bon les datations sont pas sont pas
bonnes façons pas vraiment on peut pas
vraiment si fier le fossile tout est
cohérent avec une identification comme
un 10 proto d'hondt rien est cohérent
avec une identification comme indice
hinault dont tu donc rideau ce n'était
pas un dc naudon du crétacé articles
suivants
et vous avez vu certainement passer
cette image aussi dans vos fils
d'actualité vous qui êtes passionné de
paléontologie
d'autant que c'est un article franco
suisse qu'il a publié cette image c'est
la possibilité la découverte finalement
d'une tortue qui aurait été écrasé par
un sauropode donc l'image est assez
nette de ce point de vue là donc le la
carapace de tortue aura été complètement
écrabouillé par ce gros pied de
sauropodes
alors cet article il nous vient comme je
le disais de chercheurs franco suisse
hop voilà donc voici le titre sous les
pieds d'un sauropode une tortue marine
qui a été écrasée dans le jurassique
supérieur de suisse donc vous voyez
cette brochette de co-auteur de co
auteur franco suisse je n'en connais
aucun donc et c'est un article de
taphonomie donc donc c'est pas c'est je
vais dire ça explique totalement que je
ne les connaissent pas puisque ce sont
essentiellement je suppose des géologues
on peut voir les donc quand vous savez
pas d'où viennent les gens vous vérifiez
la des petits chiffres ça vous indiquant
fait d'où ils viennent les gens
donc vous voyez section d'archéologie et
de paléontologie de l'office de culture
de l'art et la république et canton du
jura porrentruy
voilà donc je connais aucun
paléontologues de porrentruy donc c'est
pour ça et le musée d'histoire naturelle
de bâle
là par contre je connais des gens musée
d'histoire naturelle de bâle mais pas
ces gens là daniel marty c'est daniel
marty qui vient du musée d'histoire
naturelle de bâle
donc bon bref si ce sont des géologues
ça explique aussi pourquoi je je les
connais pas je ne suis pas j'ai eu là où
je suis paléontologues
donc voilà le maintenant l'idée est ce
que c'est vraiment voilà ça ça a été un
peu survendu par les par les médias
parce qu'évidemment quand vous imaginez
que quelques de retrouver quelque chose
qui a été piétiné par un sauropode
évidemment vous sentez le gros titre put
à clic vous venir en pleine face donc la
vraie la question c'est est ce qu'on
peut vraiment croire à cette
interprétation est la réponse et voilà
la réponse est bof
c'est disons que alors jeu comme je les
dis je suis pas géologue j'suis pas
taffonneau mist donc j'ai du mal à je
vais avoir du mal à critiquer toute la
partie taphonomie de l'article qui est
la partie la plus importante de
l'article au final donc oui décrivent en
fait ils décrivent que la carapace en
elle-même a été d'abord enfouis a
commencé à fossilisé puis alors été
piétinées et en fait on ils ont l'air de
voir sur la carapace qu'en fait il ya le
piétinement aurait fait tourner
légèrement certains éléments de la
carapace de 7 degrés avant que le pied
en fait relâche sa prise sur la carapace
donc je peux pas vraiment évaluer ça
parce que je ne suis pas spécialiste par
contre ce que je peux évaluer c'est là
que c'est tout simplement la question
est ce que cette tortue a été retrouvé
dans une empreinte de pas et la réponse
est non ça ils le disent assez
clairement donc donc on ça veut dire que
c'est très très spéculatif
voilà la gg surligner un passage où il
dit ça a été retrouvé sous une couche
qui contient des pistes à empreintes de
dinosaures
voilà et après il ya un autre passage
que j'ai surligner plus bas voilà où il
explique voilà que le donc
ah mais non ça c'est un autre truc les
en gros il ya un autre passage à un
endroit où ils disent voilà que c'est
que ça a été retrouvé proche d'une d'une
empreinte de enfin d'une piste
d'empreintes de dinosaures mais c'est
pas possible de comparer le l'endroit où
la torture a été retrouvé avec les
empreintes de dinosaures donc on ne sait
pas si cette tortue a été retrouvé à
l'intérieur d'une empreintes de
dinosaures en fait et donc la formation
a été perdu il semblerait donc est ce
que cette tortue a réellement été
piétinées
la réponse est bof bof là vous voyez
c'est une section du plâtre dans lequel
la tortue a été trouvé enfin dans lequel
la tortue a été extraite donc ils ont un
peu perdu la formation taphonomie qu en
extrayant la carapace de tortue et ça
c'est dommage
et de toute façon le dinosaure eux mêmes
leur conclusion est très différente de
ce que la presse a pu en vendre
puisqu'en fait le dinosaure à marcher
sur la tortue alors qu'elle était déjà
enfouie et ça c'est important voilà il a
lassé écrit à piétiner une tortue déjà
morte et enterrée
donc elle était déjà en cours de
fossilisation quand le dinosaure est
passé dessus donc même si c'est même si
le piétinement a effectivement eu lieu
et on n'a aucune preuve de sa
directement ce piétinement il a eu lieu
bien après que la tortue soit morte donc
on perd un peu tout le côté un peu
impressionnant que qu'on peut s'imaginer
à la lecture d'un titre plus ta clique
du genre une tortue piétinées à mort par
un dinosaure qua non elle n'a pas été
piétinées à mort elle était déjà morte
et on n'est même pas sûr qu'elle a été
réellement piétiner puisqu'elle n'a pas
été retrouvé dans une empreinte de pas
voilà désolé de briser vos rêves et on
va finir ce vrac avec un petit peu
d'auto promotion voilà parce qu'il ya un
article habib sy qui est sorti cet été
et c'est un article sur l'évolution du
cerveau chez les éléphants ou en fait on
a étudié la première base de données on
a formé la première base de données de
deux tailles de cerveau chez les
éléphants actuels et fossile donc la
première grande base de données et on
l'a analysé avec une méthode de
reconstruction phylogénétique basé sur
le maximum de vraisemblance donc c'est
une méthode statistique voilà qui permet
de reconstituer les états ancestraux
donc ça permet un peu de combler les
trous parce qu'au final il ya 200
espèces connues d'éléphants fossiles on
a réussi à trouver des cerveaux que pour
17 d'entre elles donc évidemment il ya
des gros trous dans la base de données
et donc pour reconstituer ces trous dans
la base de données on a fait une
reconstitution des terres ancestrales et
alors ce qu'on a trouvé c'est plutôt
intéressant voilà le l'arbre
phylogénétique et bien c'est une
augmentation générale de la taille du
cerveau que le cerveau le plus gros
n'appartient pas aux éléphants moderne
mais à un éléphant et un l'éléphant d'un
de sicile paléo loxodonta la connerie
donc voilà un gros cerveau n'est pas une
fin en soi on ne le répétera jamais
assez on peut être une espèce et avec un
plus gros cerveau que les espèces
modernes et en fait ce qu'on a découvert
c'est que on il ya deux gros saut dans
l'évolution de la taille du cerveau chez
les éléphants donc ce qu'on appelle le
quotient dans ses valises à sion le
quotient de taille du cerveau il ya un
premier saut qui a lieu à l'oligocène et
un deuxième saut qui a lieu au début du
miocène et ça ça correspond à des
changements climatiques très important
et du coup on n'a aucune idée de ce que
ça veut dire voilà faut bien l'admettre
il faut bien l'admettre les choses on
n'a aucune idée de ce que ça veut dire
mais c'est quand même une coïncidence
assez intéressante
donc voilà que les sauts en fait dans la
hâte dans l'augmentation de la taille du
cerveau ait eu lieu en même temps que
dès que des changements climatiques
alors est ce que le cerveau étant
justement l'organe qui produit le plus
de chaleur
d'où la nécessité d'ailleurs d'évacuer
cette chaleur dont on parlait avec le
premier article le cerveau produisant de
la chaleur est ce que le fait qu'ils
aient eu des glaciations
à un certain moment de ligue hossein a
joué sur l'augmentation de la taille du
cerveau
est ce que c'est juste un effet
secondaire de l'augmentation de la
taille parce que c'est aussi à cette
époque là que les éléphants commence à
devenir de grosses de gros animaux vous
voyez aussi un saut dans la taille du
corps de 2 2 tonnes à 6 tonnes quasiment
donc ça c'est pas négligeable non plus
est ce que c'est
est ce que le cerveau a juste évolué en
tant que passager voilà tout a grandit
donc est ce que le cerveau a grandi
aussi est ce que est ce que est ce que
on est face à une
est-ce que la taille du cerveau a généré
plus de mars cérébrale et du coup les
éléphants sont devenus plus intelligent
ça leur a permis de mieux survivre
notamment parce que ça leur a donné
ça leur aurait donné une plus grande
flexibilité comportement comportementale
c'est à dire que en gros au lieu de
s'adapter directement au lieu au lieu
d'attendre que la sélection naturelle
les parm leur permettent de s'adapter à
ces changements climatiques en gros ils
sont capables de réagir directement un
verre avec leur intellect c'est
exactement ce que les humains font
voilà ça c'est la grosse gros point
d'interrogation aucune cet article
n'apporte aucune réponse à ses questions
mais il a le mérite de les poser voilà
et c'est nous qu'on l'a écrit donc si
vous voulez allez le voir il est open
access le titre c'est l'évolution du
cerveau chez les proboscidiens à travers
le cénozoïque avec des collègues
français des collègues un collègue qui
vient de moldavie deux collègues pardon
de moldavie et un collègue sud africain
voilà mais il est maintenant temps
d'attaquer le gros morceau de cette
vidéo est le gros morceau de cette vidéo
ce sont les énormes annonces qui ont été
faites à travers tout cet été à propos
de l'évolution humaine et on commence
avec cette image cette image que vous
avez peut-être vu passer dans votre fil
d'actualité encore une fois
d'un crâne est donc enfin d'un crâne
humain ou du moins d'un crâne fossile
humain et qu'on vous a et qui était
certainement sous titré découverte d'un
crâne d'homo sapiens en grèce est vieux
de 200 mille ans et bien ce crâne n'a
que vous voyez là c'est pas du tout un
crâne d'homo sapiens vieux de 200 mille
ans le crâne d'homo sapiens lieu de 200
mille ans et celui là voilà c'est ce
truc là la voilà donc c'est pas un crâne
déjà c'est un morceau de crâne et déjà
ça ça fait toute la nuance déjà ça
inclut de la nuance un peu à ce que vous
avez pu voir sur internet
vous avez aussi pu voir éventuellement
une autre image dans les médias
et cette image je vais vous la montrer
c'est s est s était pas celle là hop
voilà celle ci donc l'article est un peu
lourd il a du mal à charger il ya
beaucoup de grosses d'image dedans mais
voilà vous avez pu vous aussi voir cet
article sous avec présenté avec une
image sous cette forme là et alors là
c'est carrément c'est carrément
malhonnête de titres et un crâne d'homo
sapiens de 200 milles en montrant que ce
crâne là qui est justement pas un crâne
d'homo sapiens donc en fait tout cela
vient d'un article qui est cet article
pardon je reviens là haut voilà tout
paru dans nature et qui s'intitule la
cave d'api dima et les faux falala la
cave la grotte pardon les fossiles de la
grotte d'api dima livres les plus
anciens d'ancêtres d'homo sapiens en
eurasie donc l'eurasie c'est la
contraction d'asie et d'europe donc et
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai enfin c'est
vrai on va voir que on va voir que c'est
raisonnable comme hypothèse mais c'est
juste la façon dont ça a été vendu je
trouve ça d'une malhonnêteté mais
affligeante
voilà vous montrer cette photo en vous
disant un crâne humain dom
un crâne d'homo sapiens vieux de cent
mille ans alors que c'est cette voie là
ça c'est ça c'est un néandertal et ça se
voit au premier coup d'oeil il n'y a pas
besoin d'être d'être expert donc
rappelez vous je vous vous rappelez la
vidéo que j'ai fait sur l'évolution
humaine je vous ai donné un petit type
ce qui est de regarder l'expression du
regard
si le regard à l'air méchant ces homo
heidelbergensis si le regard à l'air
triste ces homo sapiens si le regard à
l'air neutre avec les bourrelets sus
orbitaire séparés au milieu et bas c'est
un néandertal et ça il n'y a pas de
doute là-dessus cette année en der
talent il ya aussi d'autres caractères
néandertaliens assez évident sur ce
crâne
ici il n'y a pas de alors il n'y a pas
ce qu'on appelle la fosse canine c'est à
dire sur un homo sapiens ou sur un homo
erectus par exemple le contour de la
joue ferait ça en fait
cric et claque il y aurait une petite
annotation ici en fait là il n'y a pas
d'entente à sion s'est directement ops
et
transition l'iss jusqu'à la barre post
orbitaire entre la mâchoire et la base
pour la barre post orbitaire donc ça
c'est très néandertaliens est évidemment
un cerveau vous voyez à une boîte
crânienne au blond au possible même si
elle n'est pas complète on voit quand
même que elle était plutôt oblongue que
ronde
donc voilà ça vendre vendre un article
en remettant la photo de ce truc là et
en disant que ces homo sapiens c'est du
vol
donc mais l'article en lui même qui
décrit donc les restes humains qui
viennent de la grotte d'api dima en
grèce là par contre j'ai pas trop à
contester le contenu lui-même de
l'article donc ils décrivent ces deux
fossiles donc celui-là comme un
néandertal et ils se demandent en fait
ceux ci celui là c'est aussi un
néandertal ce qui était le réglage par
défaut on va dire si vous trouvez un
beau crâne de néandertal et qu'à côté
dans la même note vous trouvez un autre
morceau de crâne moins joli vous allez
tout de suite vous dire j'ai
probablement un autre néandertal mais il
se trouve que en faisant des analyses
alors des analyses du contour du peu
qu'on a alors c'est un morceau de boîte
crânienne
mais il ya quand même des différences
notables sur la boîte crânienne de
néandertal et sapiens donc quand on fait
des analyses du contour de la boîte
crânienne et là hop voilà donc ça c'est
le contour en vue de profil de la boîte
crânienne et bien néandertal il a il a
une chimio occipital voilà c'est ce
qu'on appelle le chignon occipital ce
que homo sapiens n'a pas donc ya pas de
chignons occipital ce qui donne à la
forme d' homo sapiens une une belle
forme globulaires et si on cherche les
fossiles d'api dima est bien on constate
que happy dima
le crâne api dima alors je sais plus ils
ont des numéros différents on va
vérifier donc ces api dima numéro 2
c'est le néanderthal et happy dima
numéro un c'est le sait le sapiens dont
cap isimat numéro un on va voir qu'ils
tombent
parmi les homo sapiens alors que pi dima
2 lui il tombe avec les néandertal donc
ça se voit pas trop sur sur ce graphique
là parce qu'ils n'ont pas utilisé les
mêmes les mêmes de les mêmes contours
exactement mais là ça se voit bien donc
les sapiens sont en bleu ici et donc api
dima premier tombe complètement dans les
dents les homo sapiens donc là vous avez
le crâne de skull en israël les crânes
de cas faisait aussi en israël qui sont
les plus vieux homo sapiens sapiens
anatomiquement modernes j'entends un
commencez pas à me sortir les sapiens
celui du maroc notamment irun djebel
irujo bayrou dont il tombe complètement
pas d'ailleurs puisqu'on en parle djebel
et rudi tombe complètement dans
dans les néandertal pour le couple donc
c'est dommage mais et ça va être un
petit peu la nuance aussi voyait la
jebel et roudil est là jebali rhodia 2
il ya deux fragments la up et il tombe
côté néandertaliens de la force mais
bref là où je veux en venir c'est qu'il
ya de bonnes raisons quand même de
croire que ce petit que ce petit bout de
crâne
il appartiendrait à homo sapiens et il a
été datée de 200 mille ans et donc et ça
se voit aussi pareil quand on revient
aux fossiles lui-même on voit que
l'arrière de la boîte crânienne et bien
arrondi et ne forment pas un chignon
occipital donc une boîte crânienne bien
globulaires ce qui ce qui est un
caractère d'homo sapiens donc il ya de
bonnes raisons de croire que ce petit
crâne appartient homo sapiens oui mais
il ya quand même il ya quand même la
nuance notables qui est que des restes
plus complet comme ceux de djebel i
would eux tombent
parmi les néandertaliens donc la
discrimination de ces la puissance
discrimine attriste de ces analyses
qu'ils ont fait a quand même ses limites
et elle permet pas notamment de
discriminer complètement des homo
sapiens dit archaïque des néandertal
donc déjà ça c'est c'est quelque chose
de qu'il faut remarquer et puis après il
ya la fameuse date de 200 mille ans
parce que si on a un homo sapiens en
grèce il y à 200 milles en bas ça
repousse quand même d'à peu près alors
il me semble que la sortie d' homo
sapiens de d'afrique maintenant on est
on a tendance à le repousser
cent soixante mille ans voilà le
consensus s'est assis autour de 160
mille ans qui est une combinaison en
fait des restes archéologiques
retrouvées en israël justement et en
arabie saoudite
non pardon pas encore l'arabie saoudite
j vient après des restes retrouvés en
israël et des datations moléculaire donc
anthony quand on utilise l'horloge
moléculaire c'est aussi à peu près la
date qu'on a donc le consensus est
arrêté autour de 168 milan oui mais
on a découvert donc en arabie saoudite
des restes d'homo sapiens qui aurait 180
mille ans mais qui sont très maigrichon
il s'agit d'une phalange je crois et de
quelques petites choses par ci par là
donc donc peut-être une sortie d'afrique
à 180 mille ans mais pas sûr on a
retrouvé en chine des restes d'homo
sapiens qui ont 210 mille ans mais
encore une fois c'est surtout des outils
et il n'ya pas d'ossements encore donc
c'est juste une industries lithiques qui
est typique d'homo sapiens mais et non
pas d'homo erectus qui est censé être
l'humain qui vivait en chine
à cette époque là donc encore une fois
les doutes sont permis
donc là si maintenant qu'on a un crâne
qui a l'air vraiment d'être homo sapiens
en grèce il ya deux cent mille ans
attendrait a confirmé que l'être humain
est bien sortie de d'afrique il ya deux
cent mille ans donc juste après être
apparue puisque les premiers crâne
d'homo sapiens moderne finalement et
enfin les premiers restes d'homo sapiens
considéré moderne on de rond autour de
200 mille ans donc voilà voilà
et après vous avez homo sapiens
archaïque qui seraient apparues il ya
trois cent mille ans puisqu'on a le
crâne dix rounds de djebel est rude
qui est alors qu'ils aient au moins qui
est considéré comme homo sapiens moderne
par les auteurs de parts par les auteurs
de des gens qui ont décrit en fait ce
crâne c'est considéré comme homo sapiens
moderne ya rien de moderne dans le crâne
de djebel est rude et cette analyse du
coup le confirme bien on trouve diabelli
route du côté néandertaliens dans
quasiment toutes les analyses a envoyé
djebel est rude après il se trouve quand
même pas loin du chevauchement voyez
qu'il ya quand même un des deux crânes
là par exemple ces jobs lire ou de
numéro un qui se retrouvent sur le
chevauchement avec sapiens sapiens
moderne est ici vous avez ir août 2 qui
se retrouve aussi sur le chevauchement
avec sapiens moderne donc c'est un crâne
donc c'est pas un crâne de
néandertaliens non plus il n'est pas du
côté néandertaliens complètement de la
force sur ces analyses là c'est les
analystes d'ailleurs qui correspondrait
aux analyses de la face donc la phase
serait plus modernes chez djebel est
rude mais par contre la boîte crânienne
le place complètement
du côté des néandertaliens donc jebali
rudi y en a là et l'autre est ici et là
du bel air où il y en a et l'autre est
ici donc vous voyez bien séparées à
chaque fois de d'homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes
contrairement au crâne de grèce du coup
et donc donc ça rapporte du nouveau ça
alors ça pose pas mal de questions du
coup s'il est si l'être humain est
effectivement sortis d'afrique il ya
deux cent mille ans à ça ça pose la
question est ce qu'il y aurait pas eu
trois migration d'homo sapiens en dehors
d'afrique puisque pour l'instant on est
sur un consensus à 2 migration une
première qui a été une première qui a
été avortée il ya 160 mille ans et une
deuxième qui aurait fonctionné il ya 80
mille ans enfin entre 100 et 80 mille
ans et du coup est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas eu une une troisième migration il y
a deux cent mille ans voire avant ça qui
aurait aussi raté mais qui aurait quand
même emmené homo sapiens jusqu'en chine
et jusqu'en grèce mais qui l'aurait et
du coup ça ça se connectent aussi avec
les hybridations les nombreuses traces
d'hybridation qu'on a pu trouver dans
l'année n-2 néandertal et de sapiens
donc si hybridation il y a eu et si
enfin voilà ça tout ça se met ensemble
et commence et contribue à réécrire en
fait cette histoire de d'homo sapiens en
dehors d'afrique dans ces eaux là quoi
donc donc donc fait attention à ce qu'on
vous dit dans la presse voilà la morale
de cette histoire c'est pas la morale de
cette histoire c'est pas comme au
sapiens sont pas sortis d'afrique il ya
deux cent mille ans et c'est une
possibilité qui était déjà envisagée
avant la publication de cet article mais
alors par contre quand on vous montre
quand on vous montre ça en vous disant
que ces homo sapiens à la place de ça
ben voilà et voilà de le vrai restes
d'homo sapiens c'est ça donc bon faut
pas faut pas non plus
à gérer quoi faut faire attention à pas
se faire piéger
l'article suivant
hop je passe l'article suivant
c'est un article donc qui parle aussi de
l'origine d'homo sapiens est encore une
fois avec un investissement de deux
chercheurs français dans le lot donc
aurélien mounier qui nous vient donc qui
nous vient qui nous vient du muséum
national du muséum d'histoire naturelle
de paris et du musée de l'homme donc
donc contribution française à la
question de à quoi donc ressembler
l'ancêtre l'ancêtre commun d'homo
sapiens et donc pour ça ils ont utilisé
une technique assez pointu qui consiste
à mettre des landmarks donc des petits
points partout sur des crânes
digitalisées ou numérisés si vous
préférez parce qu'il ya des guerriers
rose de la langue française qui aime pas
qu on utilise le mot digital bref donc
numérisés donc ils ont mis ça sur tout
le crâne pour pouvoir quantifier en fait
la forme du crâne
chez homo sapiens donc et vous voyez
qu'ils ont utilisés des populations
d'homo sapiens essentiellement moderne
et ce justement de 2k faisait et de
skull donc les tout premiers homo
sapiens moderne d'israël et ils ont fait
tourner une analyse qui permet de
reconstituer l'état de caractère
ancestral mais pour tousser
pour les quantités que représente chacun
de ces landmark et du coup ça bon ben ça
représente une énorme série de chiffres
qui peut être retraduite ensuite en une
forme et cette forme et bien c'est la
forme de votre de votre ancêtre commun
en fait donc voilà à quoi ressemblait
voilà le crâne de l'ancêtre commun
d'homo sapiens ce à quoi il devait
ressembler même si en soit on trouvera
probablement jamais le crâne qui
correspond à ça donc ça c'est plutôt
fort et alors là la façon dont ils ont
pu atteindre ce résultat en fait c'est
juste encore une fois vous transformez
le crâne la forme du crâne en quantité
et bien cette quantité ces quantités
peuvent être analysés par analysant
composante principale donc c'est ce que
vous voyez là et en fait il suffit
ensuite de redessiner le l'arbre
phylogénétique par dessus cette analyse
en composante principale afin de voir où
se trouve pouf d'ancêtre commun
voilà donc l'ancêtre commun vous avez un
espace qui est dit morphologiques ici
avec des espèces des individus qui sont
qui se disent qu'ils sont distribués sur
cet espace morphologiques donc ici les
homo sapiens ici des néandertal ici les
les homos primitif et bien en prenant le
point de cet espace morphologiques qui
correspond à l'ancêtre commun et bien
vous pouvez dire ok voilà à quoi
ressemble vous pouvez être ré extraire
finalement les coordonner tous les poux
toutes les coordonnées toutes les toutes
les quantités qui se trouve à ce point
de l'espace morphologiques et
reconstituer le crâne primitif d'homo
sapiens donc le crâne de l'ancêtre
commun de me sapiens et voici donc un
quoi il devait ressembler donc on
retrouve la forme globulaires du crâne
on retrouve cette fameuse indentation
dont je vous parlais la voyez le
maxillaire ici tac qui forment une
petite annotation et qui n'est pas
continu comme chez néandertal on
retrouve
la réduction du boulet supra orbitaire
encore que là on est sur un homo sapiens
on est sur un homo sapiens qui devait
vivre il ya deux cent à trois cent mille
ans donc il ya un petit rebord quand
même qui est visible on retrouve une
absence de projection de la face vers
l'avant contrairement à beaucoup
d'autres beaucoup d'autres représentants
du genre homo mais il ya quand même vous
voyez une petite petite projection est
donc ce crâne
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant ensuite c'est
de le comparer à tous les crânes
fossiles qui n'ont pas été inclus dans
l'analyse
bah oui parce qu'on va pas le comparer
au crâne qui ont été inclus dans
l'analyse sinon vous vous mordez là que
évidemment mais voyez qu'ils n'ont
utilisé que les tous premiers homo
sapiens hors d'afrique pour pour faire
cette analyse donc ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est de le comparer du
cou à tous ceux qui ont ils tous les
homos sapiens supposer qu'ils ont été
couvent retrouver en afrique et ça et ça
du coup ça vous donne ce cette figure là
et donc ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que ben en le comparant à tous les
homos sapiens d'afrique et bien le celui
qui ressemble le plus c'est le mossad
c'est le
alors un spécimen qui a souvent été
appelé au mot et le pays où vous bien et
d'albert guentis mais qui qui est en
fait le crâne de floris bad donc
retrouver en afrique du sud et qui date
de deux cent cinquante six mille ans
donc ce crâne il a des petits bourrelets
sus orbitaire il a un front qui est vous
le voyez légèrement fuyant comme celui
de cet homo sapiens reconstitué au lieu
d'avoir un affront bien verticale il a
un front légèrement fuyant et il n'a pas
de museau fortement prononcé par bhl pas
de forme useo visible et pas de blessure
se rebiffe supra orbitaire fortement
prononcé non plus et donc ça c'est très
intéressant parce que ça ça pointe et
c'est aussi ce que leurs analyses en
tentant de ta montre et donc après ils
ont refait les analyses mais en incluant
cette fois les les crânes fossiles
d'afrique et ce qu'ils trouvent en fait
c'est que leurs ancêtres communs voyez
là le lc a donc leur ancêtre commun
hypothétique le crâne le plus proche
c'est celui de floris bad
voilà et encore une fois ici d'ancêtre
commun ah non là ils ont pas inclus
floris bad parce que c'est sur l'arrière
de la boîte crânienne et que floris bad
n'a pas de boîte crânienne
donc c'est juste sur cette analyse là
que floris bad ressort comme le plus
proche mais quand on a cru que la boîte
crânienne
ben en fait il ya au cas il ya aucun des
trucs africains qui ressort donc si on
peut supposer que si floris bad était là
peut-être qu'ils que ce serait lui qui
en ressortirait là et donc voilà voilà
voilà donc vous avez des candidats
évidemment qu'ils viennent d'un peu
partout en afrique vous avez donc alors
attendez on va regarder dans la légende
sommes donc dans la légende
on a au mot 2 donc qui vient de
l'afrique de l'est est lâché l âge 18
qui vient aussi d'afrique de l'est donc
tant d annie kenya etc
ça vient d'eux par là donc floris bad
qui est le troisième cas est né e s qui
vient aussi du coup de
d'afrique de l'est et le fameux crâne de
jebel el aroud donc le fameux crâne du
maroc
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant vallat par
rapport à ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure le crâne de diabelli roudil est
marrant parce que la boîte crânienne
vous voyez elle a un chignon un énorme
chignon occipital qui fêterait
néandertaliens mais la face elle est un
peu plus sapiens que néandertalienne par
contre c'est de l'homo sapiens très très
archaïque 1 vous voyez un gros bourg les
supports orbitaire vous voyez un un
petit museau l'a bien proéminent l'a
comparé à ce qu'on peut voir ici via un
petit museau un petit museau bien
visible quand même et une robuste ici
une robuste is it et du visage en
général très très prononcé donc donc gb
lire ou d' homo sapiens oui mais alors
moderne
ouais non probablement pas moderne et là
vous avez définitivement deux analyses
qui ont été publiés qui ont l'air de
bien indiquer que oui c'est pas pour
rien qu'il est vieux de 300 mille ans il
a vraiment une anatomie qui est sapiens
oui mais alors très archaïque donc donc
comparé par exemple à celui là le knm us
de d'afrique de l'est là où vous voyez
que les bourrelets sus orbitaire sont
beaucoup plus fin et qu' il n'y a pas de
museau et il ya une boîte crânienne bien
globulaires donc ça on est beaucoup plus
sûr du sapiens la résine visiblement du
sapiens anatomiquement beaucoup plus
moderne et donc floris bat serait le
plus anatomiquement proche finalement de
cet ancêtre commun
donc c'est plutôt intéressant c'est
plutôt intéressant parce que sa pointe
du doigt finalement à spécimens sud
africain et quand on sait en regardant
quand on constate en regardant la
phylogénie des des humains modernes donc
phylogénique est basé sur les caractères
des caractères moléculaire donc de la
deûle à de l'adn et bien on voit qu'en
fait les populations humaines modernes
qui sont le plus à la base de l'arbre
eh bien elles viennent d'afrique
évidemment puisque l'homme est
originaire d'afrique mais les plus
banales et bien ce sont les causes and
que vous voyez ici avec les pygmées qui
viennent de
d'afrique centrale donc on est vraiment
sur une origine au sud de l'afrique
et si on ajoute du coup que le plus
proche de l'ancêtre commun ici c'est un
crâne qui vient de floris bad donc
d'afrique du sud bat géographiquement ça
veut dire que toute cette région là de
l'arbre elle est quand même fortement
attachés au sud de l'afrique
donc ça ça contredit aussi bas déjà ça
contredit du coup les conclusions que
l'article à propos du crâne de jebali
route qui place l origine de l'homme en
afrique du nord
et ça contredit aussi certaines analyses
moléculaires qui avait envie de deux
complètement botté en touche la question
de la géographie en disant mais l'homme
il est originaire de partout en afrique
ben voilà bon oui mais enfin l'évolution
c'est un peu plus enfin je sais pas
comment comment une population en ces
strahl peut-être toute l'afrique
quand on sait quand on sait d'après la
diversité génétique qu'ils n'étaient
qu'une poignée je veux dire il n'était
même pas un million ils s'étaient même
port je sais même pas s'ils étaient cent
mille en réalité les humains à l'époque
quoi donc comment est ce qu'on peut dire
que cette population était à l'échelle
de toute l'afrique alors qu'ils étaient
si peu nombreux quoi ça me semble quand
même un peu bizarre donc avoir une
origine géographique
un peu plus resserré comme ça déjà ça me
semble un peu plus un peu plus faisable
on va dire voilà maintenant reculons
dans le temps et allons voir du côté des
australopithèques donc on remonte on
remonte dans le passé et on va voir nos
ancêtres les cousins de lucy avec la
découverte de ce crâne donc très très
jolie crâne plutôt bien préservé deux
australopithèques hussan à mennecy ce
qui est donc qui s'était créé ici si
vous voulez savoir comment ça s'écrit
australopithèques us and à mennecy ce
qui est le plus vieil australopithèques
puisqu'il a vécu autour de 4 millions
d'années donc il est plus vieux que lui
si il est même un petit peu plus vieux
que little foot voilà et il vient
d'afrique de l'est
et donc c'est une découverte
intéressante parce que c'est
australopithecus afarensis et que
australopithecus afarensis il était
surtout connu par ses dents et pas
tellement par son par sa tête
donc maintenant on a un crâne
d'australopithecus honda mène six mais
après c'est la morphologie crânienne
d'un australopithèque classique 1 petite
boîte crânienne énorme mâchoire museau
proéminent canine très très large c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça qu'ils ont réussi à
attribuer ce crâne à australopithecus
afarensis parce que comme je voulais dit
le le taxon and à mennecy c'est connu
surtout par saison vous voyez l'état des
dents sur celui là vous vous dites mais
comment ils ont fait pour dire que
c'était un homme n 6 bon ils ont regardé
la canine parce que la canine
apparemment elle est très très spécial
chez anna mensis elle est très très
larges très très robuste et du coup il a
canine est est très similaire entre ce
spécimen là et les autres spécimens de
la mène 6 et puis voilà quoi c'est
surtout ça qui est intéressant par
rapport à ceux cette découverte donc
gros gros articles dans nature's avec
des grosses autorités dedans à à l
sélassié évidemment qui en première
auteure qui est une grosse autorité en
la matière mais bon finalement ça
enfonce un peu des portes ouvertes
puisque puisqu'un amène 6 au final il
est situé dans l'arbre phylogénétique
humain il est situé entre
l'australopithecus entre lucie donc
australopithecus afarensis et
ardipithecus et donc ardipithecus et
australopithecus afarensis ils sont pas
si différents en terme de morphologie
crânienne 1 c'est surtout la morphologie
des pieds qui est très différent
afarensis est très très dérivés comparé
au niveau des pieds
comparé à didier cuche mais bon voilà
c'est quand même intéressant d'avoir
maintenant ce crâne qui vient confirmer
finalement la position d'un amène 6 à la
base de l'arbre phylogénétique humains
d'ailleurs j'y pense mais cet article il
est très notable par le fait qu'il
adopte justement une
un point de vue phylogénétique parce que
ça c'est très très rare dans les
articles de paléoanthropologie que les
paliers entre open de faire des analyses
cladistique pour confirmer la position
phylogénétique de leurs spécimens et
bien dans cet article là ils l'ont fait
donc ça c'est quand même important de le
souligner c'est pas juste des quantités
c'est pas juste des comparaisons et du
pifomètre
il ya quand même une formalisation des
hypothèse phylogénétique sous forme d'
analyse cladistique loin de moi l'idée
de dire que les analyses cladistique
c'est l'avenir c'est beau c'est
magnifique ça ne fait aucune erreur
c'est pas le cas c'est jusqu'à au moins
ça donne un cadre de répétabilité à vos
hypothèse phylogénétique c'est à dire
que quelqu'un peut venir derrière vous
regardez votre méthode et vous dire ok à
cet endroit de la méthode je suis pas
d'accord et on peut changer ça et voir
quel effet ça sur le résultat final donc
ça c'est quand même vachement important
c'est un grand pas en avant de voir des
recherches de paléoanthropologie avec
des analyses et statistiques
systématiques
voilà
c'est bon c'est pas les premiers à
l'avoir fait a vu qu'ils ont récupéré
eux mêmes des analyses cladistique qui
venait d'ailleurs d'autres articles mais
ce serait quand même bien de voir ça se
systématiser dans le futur et donc là on
l'a ce crâne il confirme la position
d'al ameen 6 comme je le disais entre
ramidus et afarensis comme vous pouvez
le voir ici est l'une des grosses
conclusion de l'article est bien c'est
justement de faire déjà envie de dire de
faire sécession avec justement la vision
anna génétique de l'évolution humaine
c'est à dire qu'en gros anna même si
c'était considéré comme l'ancêtre direct
daf à rennes 6 voilà c'est quand même
une grosse hypothèse faut bien le dire
surtout quand on n'a que des dents
ancêtres directs alors qu'on a quasiment
rien du machin à part une date qui
effectivement plus ancienne que celle
daf à rennes 6 mais bon c'est le plus
ancien des australopithèques alors
pourquoi pas l'ancêtre de n'importe quel
autre bref
donc voila c'était quand même c'était
quand même une grosse hypothèse qui
était basé sur pas grand chose et là du
coup ils ont complètement fait sécession
avec cette hypothèse en déclarant que la
dame n si ce n'était certainement pas
l'ancêtre d'afar n 6 déjà parce que ils
ont constaté que sur le crâne
anna mène 6 à des caractères cafard n 6
n'a pas et qu'ils en fassent ce sont des
cra ce sont des caractères dit haute à
pommeau refik donc des caractères qui
sont propres à un amène 6 et uniquement
à 1 mn 6 donc ça exclut une ancestralité
direct avec une autre espèce
et quelle quelle que soit l'espèce en
question mais surtout ils ont identifié
en fait qu'il y avait un autre morceau
de crâne qui avait été attribuée à un
amène 6 parce qu'il était vieux donc
c'est un tout petit fragment de crâne
qui avait été attribuée à un amen 6
parce qu'il était vieux d'à peu près 4
millions d'années et au final et bien il
ne correspond pas à la morphologie dan
ammann 6 mai au contraire la morphologie
daf avensis donc du coup bah c'est ce
qui c'est ce dont il discute l'a1
ils disent que du coup le
ce fragment il n'appartient plus
peut-être plus afarensis ce qui veut
dire qu afarensis et en amène si c'était
probablement contemporain voilà donc
afarensis a probablement vécu autour de
3 8 millions d'années donc
donc s'ils étaient contemporains anna
même si ce ne peut pas être l'ancêtre
daf à 26 donc j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup cet article parce que il jette
vraiment il jette vraiment des grosses
bases pour l'utilisation en faveur de
l'utilisation systématique de
d'analystes phylogénétique qu'elle soit
cladistique ou autre en
paléoanthropologie et enfin le dernier
article
c'est un article dont vous avez alors
vous avez probablement pas vu le titre
où aucune des figures ce que vous avez
pu en voir c'est ça donc vous avez
certainement vu cette image passée à
propos de cet article donc un bassin de
chimpanzés un bassin intermédiaires et
un bassin de gori si je ne m'abuse
parce que ça n'a pas l'air du tout
d'être un bassin homo sapiens bassanne
homo sapiens me serais beaucoup plus
large et donc cet article
était souvent accompagnée d'une d'un
titre put à cliquer encore une fois qui
dit une forme intermédiaire entre entre
les hominidés qui éclaire sur l'origine
de la bipédie chez l'homme ou un truc
comme ça quoi et en fait non pas du tout
c'est pas du tout ça que qui s'est
produit donc c'est un article qui parle
d'un d'un fragment de bassin qui a été
retrouvée en hongrie
donc qui a été publiée par des parts des
américains essentiellement
dont david begun qui est l'autorité
suprême en termes de dominer enfin
domino id mais qui ne sont pas des
hominidés
justement vous pas des homininés quoi
ils ne sont pas de la lignée humaine
donc voilà c'est lui l'autorité suprême
donc c'est plutôt du sérieux donc voilà
en noir les fragments qui ont été
retrouvés un donc c'est pas c'est pas
grand chose et on peut d'ailleurs leur
reprocher parce qu'il ya un moment dans
de l'article où il déclare qu'il ya
aussi un fémur
par exemple et qu'il ya aussi des dents
et qu'il ya d'autres morceaux donc ils
ont l'air de vouloir décrire leur truc
on compte gouttes
un os à la fois donc un os un article
c'est du bon rendement et donc donc
c'est bizarre en fait ouais voilà ce qui
est bizarre c'est que du coup il
c'est un article où ils décrivent la
posture de l'animal à partir du bassin
mais où ils ont finalement découvert un
fémur aussi et ils prennent pas en
compte ce que leurs deals le fémur donc
c'est quand même bizarre de décrire le
bassin d'un côté le fémur de l'autre
enfin je sais pas ce qu'ils nous
préparent avec leurs trucs mais voyez
ils sont obligés de faire des
reconstructions en 3d de la tête du
fémur alors qu'ils ont un fémur donc
c'est ça que je comprends pas alors
qu'ils déclarent avoir un fémur
donc je sais pas ce qu'ils nous
préparent avec ça est ce qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'ils sont en train de nous charger
une bombe sur l'évolution de la bipédie
je pense pas parce que de toute façon
leur truc il était à des kilomètres
d'être bipèdes et c'est d'ailleurs leur
conclusion c'est la conclusion de la fin
de l'article
le bassin correspond à un animal qui est
totalement quadrupèdes donc donc même
même le même les articles plus qu'à
cliquer là de la presse ils sont
complètement à côté de la plaque quoi
y'a jamais été question dans cet article
de bipédie quoi si on voilà voilà
si on vient ici est rude et eu ce geste
data foule suit avoir trop gras
d'adaptation caractérise style
caractérise ling extermine reid
etc etc voilà orthographe ça veut dire
la colonne vertébrale à l'horizontale
donc quadrupèdes un essai leurs
conclusions à eux donc
voilà je l'a contredit pas parce que ce
bassin il a toutes les caractéristiques
d'un bassin de quadrupèdes donc
donc quand j'ai vu l'article je me suis
mis arrivé à rêver de peut-être on
arriverait enfin à expliquer d'où
sortent les empreintes soi-disant
bipèdes qui ont été retrouvée en grèce
parce que bon on est quand même sur un
bassin qui a 10 millions d'années et
sachant qu'il ya des empreintes bipèdes
qui ont été retrouvés des empreintes de
singe bipèdes qui ont été retrouvée en
grèce et qui datent de sept millions
d'années
bon là on est en hongrie on n'est pas en
grèce mais bon ça fait quand même un
tout petit ça fait un tout petit espace
a à remplir
parce que pour pour comprendre si on
avait eu un anneau meaning and
hominoïdes qui était bipède
en hongrie il ya 10 millions d'années il
y avait quand même un peu moyen de
s'imaginer qu'il y avait de l'eau mignot
i'd be paid en grèce il ya 7 millions
d'années quoi bon au lieu de ça il
faudra toujours se contenter d'un autre
hominoïdes qui s'appelle oreo pittacus
lore hôpitaux q ce que je vous montre en
ce moment à l'image donc vous pouvez
voir c'est un très très beau squelette
est donc lui il a définitivement par
contre un bassin qui correspond beaucoup
plus habile peut être vous voyez la
largeur des ailes du bassin correspond
beaucoup plus un animal qui marchaient
sur sur deux pattes et qui du coup avait
besoin de support en fait pour ses
viscères comparé à ce bassin qui lui a
des ailes beaucoup plus étroite
donc ouais faites attention encore une
fois à ce que dit la presse
aux combinaisons aussi d'imagés de
titres parce que au final si vous lisez
les articles de presse au bout d'un
moment ils finissent par le dire que le
truc était quadrupèdes mais c'est juste
que la combinaison de l'image d'un singe
bipèdes et de l'évolution qui
révolutionne l'évolution de la bible de
la bipédie chez les hominidés forcément
vous combinez tout ça au bout d'un
moment ça vous donne l'idée que ça on
arrête et qu'on a découvert un singe
bipèdes qui vivait il ya 10 millions
d'années en europe et pouf ça change
tout à l'origine des êtres humains s'il
y avait des bipèdes en europe il ya des
millions d'années
ben non on avait déjà aurait au pit et
cusm 8 millions d'années en italie et ça
n'a pas changé l'image de l'évolution
humaine s'étaient jusque il est
interprété comme un billet bipèdes
arboricole donc il vivait comme un orang
outan bah oui parce que les orangs
outans aussi sont considérés comme biped
mais le bipède arboricole donc
donc voilà faut savoir mettre des
nuances un peu dans vos articles de
presse voilà mes mais sinon baffe comme
j'ai dit le problème c'est que c'est la
description que d'un bassin parce qu'ils
ont décidé pour une raison que j'ignore
de décrire leur matériel au
compte-gouttes donc bah voilà donc c'est
un ça montre définitivement que
l'ancêtre commun de ruud a piqué cus des
chimpanzés et des gorilles et de l'homme
du coup était quadrupèdes donc encore un
d'ailleurs au passage encore un petit
tacle à la bipédie ancestrales là pour
le coup ça mais un bon gros tacle à
l'hypothèse de la bipédie ancestrale qui
je le rappelle n'est basé sur aucun
fossile pour autant que je sache non
voilà c'était c'était la revue de toutes
les news qui a eu pendant l'été et
j'espère que du coup vous allez être
nombreux à voir ce paléo news et à
soutenir ce nouveau format
quant à moi de vous
à bientôt et n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner pour ne rien manquer d'anciens à
très bientôt
[Musique]